I want your boob out me but I think your
boobs should be iMovie Josh Smith and
today we are joined by the Queen of the
Universe and star of glass it's Sarah
Paulson well we're gonna play a game
view today yes we are to conclude it be
more Sarah oh and because I think I
might do well at it
Jesus I am see you also exactly you play
fair piss and glass I do so I'm gonna
come at you okay with some amazing
scenarios life problems I have that
inspired by the film oh you didn't help
me solved them oh I just started dating
a lad who's got many many layers to his
personality okay and I can't work out
who he really is how can I break him
down you film him at home and at the
office all day and you see what he
really is like when you're not around
and then when you gather that
information you will know just how to
get in that yeah place was trading all
day yeah yeah yeah I think that's sound
sage advice definitely I mean it is but
I don't care
you gotta get the information that you
need I was gonna say you could sit on
his face and that would then go tactics
you have to sit on his face until you
will tell me everything I want to know
where I will not get off your face and
that but I think it could work if you
position everything the right way
they're working the goodies crack yes
I'm looking to adopt a new tough-guy
image I feel lucky new - maybe like
mascot the touch now okay what tips can
you give me for bringing out my inner
Bruce Willis
um I think you could sweeten your eyes a
little bit
when you're listening put your chin down
a bit and [ __ ] your head to the side you
can't be laughing that doesn't work when
you now you don't have any Bruce Willis
put your head down squint yeah there you
go
really good sold I might give any Bruce
Willis yes you are
I just need to like bring the voices
well then I'll send your Elvis you're
like look it's really got this girl
usually done egg okay my junk passed on
to you super charismatic hey but she
needs a name watch like christen her her
name is Vivian if he was a bit of a mess
isn't she be initiated a mess but she's
so chic and glamorous but when you first
meet her if you call her Vivian you
don't know her she gets pissed yeah cuz
I feel like you probably live with quite
a lot of different personalities have
any name mostly it's like really stupid
things like grumpy Sarah irritable Sarah
but I call myself Sarah yeah it's kind
of Lights none the Dewar's yeah she's
grumpy Oh sleepy Sarah bother her she's
tight I give us some milk she's sleepy
sleep give her a little Nikki a little
bottle and enough nook now I've got a
super hero within okay and she's
desperate to come out but she's got some
bad style okay oh yeah I know it's
tragic I don't see that happening at all
omit but inside this enchanting
struggling clothing way okay what should
i style her like Vicky should have your
boobs out she's got my baby out I want
your boob out of me but I think your
boobs should be out okay great because
it's empowering
they've got fabulous ones oh so you
should all let them let the pendulum
hang let it out the Pens went through
the nip we're all about that I'm even a
star I don't want any Instagram
censoring
and while the nipples out and I want
yours out too well that can be arranged
I mean I just feel like why dress when
you look the way you do just let it be
basically become a nudist that's my
advice for your quick my job in
apartment yes because yeah you're quite
good at pulling off a stealing crime
mm-hmm and I somehow ended up in prison
I mean to work on my mug shot pose oh
yes what would you recommend because I
was kind of thinking Lindsay Lohan sack
at the time as she got darling with the
blonde and orange yeah the orange as if
she had a choice though she picked the
orange one what like a mug shot pose do
you think is a good one will you have
mascara on well I could do it okay then
you take a nice carrot and then you dip
your fingers and water and then you mush
mush mush to get like a proper smokey
eye and then cry y'all think back tears
and mascara tears running down ya brow
furrow would be good yeah but I think
it's the tears dropping with like black
mascara at the bottom and be the most
dramatic so just try very sexy trash
yeah it'll be sort of sexy well I'm
gonna wave this feeling more Sarah an
editorial trash editorial tour right
always
hashtag goal says they yeah well you're
a hashtag fire I'm hashtag fire cool the
fire brigade yeah he's on fire in here
thank you so much you're incredible